We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21centry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. It's a big majestic building on Nathan Phillips Square. And this is my friend Sean Cole in Toronto, Ontario. New City Hall.
我们获得了全球排名的大学——加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，该校致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加利福尼亚州及全球各地合作创新，以寻找变革性的解决方案。这全是该大学促进所有生物生活质量使命的一部分。请访问 21centry.ucdavis.edu 了解更多信息。这里是《99%隐形》，我是罗曼·马斯。在内森·菲利普斯广场上有一座宏伟的大楼，这位是我的朋友肖恩·科尔，他在安大略省多伦多市的新市政厅。
It's formed totally of concrete. There are these two towers that sort of curve like hands, cupped around a clamshell. So this was a big deal. When it opened in 1965. The first modern concrete civic building for Toronto inserted very prominently into the Victorian fabric. Masha Kelman used to work in the city planning office
它完全由混凝土建造。有两座塔楼像双手一样弯曲，呈贝壳状环抱。所以这可是件大事，当它于1965年开放时。多伦多第一座现代混凝土市政建筑非常显眼地插入了维多利亚式的建筑群中。玛莎·凯尔曼曾在城市规划办公室工作过
in the East Tower on floor 19. She was an architect. The building really explored and exploited the possibilities of concrete. Everything was about concrete in Toronto back then. The play of opacity versus transparency and everything. So the furniture really picked up on that. Yes, even the office furniture inside City Hall
在东塔的第19层。她是一名建筑师。这座建筑真正探索和利用了混凝土的可能性。当时的整个多伦多都围绕着混凝土。不透明与透明的交织以及一切。所以家具也真正呼应了这一点。是的，甚至连市政厅内部的办公家具
was made in part of concrete. But let's back up. In the 50s, Toronto decided that it needed a new city hall. So there was an international competition and in 58 there was a design selected by Finnish architect Biliar Revelle. But he wasn't satisfied with simply designing one of the most prominent buildings the city had ever seen. No. Reavelle proposed that he was also going to design the furniture. He wanted to design the furniture. He had a vision, but it wasn't to be.
部分也是由混凝土制成的。但让我们回顾一下。在50年代，多伦多决定需要一座新的市政厅。于是举行了一场国际竞赛，并在58年选中了芬兰建筑师维尔乔·雷韦尔的设计。但他并不满足于仅仅设计这座城市有史以来最显眼的建筑之一。不，雷韦尔还提议由他来设计家具。他想亲自设计家具。他有自己的愿景，但这未能实现。
The decision that City Hall made was to commission the furniture through a second competition. So Ravelle was very disappointed. It was very dramatic. He called it the biggest disappointment of his life. And he subsequently passed away. City Hall felt bad, or at least. They felt the weight of the responsibility. So we're the competition to someone So they gave it to a company called Noll International.
市政厅做出的决定是通过第二场比赛来委托制作家具。所以雷韦尔非常失望。这非常戏剧化。他称其为他一生中最大的失望。随后他去世了。市政厅感到内疚，或者至少他们感受到了责任的重量。所以他们把比赛交给了某个人，因此他们把它交给了一家名为诺尔国际的公司。
And it was the only design that used concrete. Desks, coffee tables, cabinets, they all had concrete legs. The mayor's desk was this sleek concrete and polished wood statement. And all of this was really expensive. And the mayor's desk was this sleek concrete and polished wood statement, and all of this was really expensive. And there was immediate public outcry about this furniture, particularly from the people who were actually using it.
这是唯一采用混凝土的设计。办公桌、咖啡桌、文件柜，它们的腿都是混凝土的。市长的办公桌是一件由混凝土和抛光木材制成的时尚作品。所有这些都非常昂贵。而且市长的办公桌是一件由混凝土和抛光木材制成的时尚作品，所有这些都非常昂贵。公众立即对这些家具提出了强烈抗议，特别是那些实际使用它们的人。
There were complaints that the desks were wobbly, and that when secretaries typed on them, they weren't sturdy. But the legs are concrete. how could it not be sturdy? It's hard to imagine, yeah. Toronto Star, furniture rouse on again. And we have, in our research file, many articles from that time, with all kinds of really interesting headlines. Globe and Mail, wobbly desks at City Hall spark new furniture controversy.
有人抱怨办公桌摇晃，秘书在上面打字时不够稳固。但桌腿是混凝土的，怎么会不稳呢？这确实很难想象。多伦多星报：家具风波再起。我们的研究档案中有很多当时的报道，有着各种各样非常有趣的标题。环球邮报：市政厅摇晃的办公桌引发了新的家具争议。
Various officials in City Hall were fighting over it. There was even one that talked about somebody quitting. Frosty George Bell went out as coordinator today after a blazing row with border control over Secretary's desk. This was the 60s and hemlines were starting to get shorter. And there was nothing to shield the Secretary's knees. Man the new desk said no drawers. Man they weren't big enough.
市政厅的各种官员为此争论不休。甚至还有一个报道提到有人辞职。弗罗斯特·乔治·贝尔今天在与边境控制就秘书办公桌爆发激烈争吵后，作为协调员离职了。这是60年代，裙摆开始变短。没有任何东西可以遮住秘书的膝盖。天哪，新桌子连抽屉都没有。天哪，它们还不够大。
But Masha Kelman has sat at that furniture. She used to work at one of those desks, and it didn't wobble. When she said, it's hard to imagine, yeah, it was because some of the complaints make no sense to her. And she has a theory. One city hall was that perhaps it was quite uncomfortable for people to internalize that this is really what they had chosen. And perhaps there was a kind of anxiety about this new modernism and
但玛莎·凯尔曼曾在那套家具前坐过。她曾在那些办公桌之一工作过，而且它并没有摇晃。当她说“这很难想象”时，那是因为有些抱怨对她来说毫无道理。她有一个理论。市政厅的一个看法是，人们可能很难接受这就是他们真正选择的东西。或许对于这种新的现代主义以及
this new concrete that we were inserting into our traditional city. So perhaps the furniture which was kind of memetic of the building. Memetic. Memetic. Relating to characteristic of or exhibiting mimicry. Okay, so perhaps the furniture which was memetic of the building. Um, really served as an outlet for that anxiety. And perhaps this is why the controversy didn't seem to me so much since.
我们植入传统城市中的这种新混凝土，人们产生了一种焦虑。所以，这种模仿建筑的家具——模仿的，模仿的，与模仿有关、具有模仿特征或表现出模仿的。好吧，所以这种模仿建筑的家具，嗯，确实成为了释放这种焦虑的发泄口。或许这就是为什么这场争议在我看来并不那么合乎逻辑的原因。
Later the complaint was that it was difficult to move and so on. So of course, you know, as City Hall began to update itself over the years, the furniture since it was not valued, it was lost just simply through replacement. It was actually thrown away. But not all of it. It's kind of like a hunt in here, a treasure hunt, looking for them, but they are here.
后来有人抱怨说它很难搬动等等。所以当然，你知道，随着市政厅多年来开始自我更新，这些家具由于不被重视，在简单的更换过程中丢失了。实际上它们被扔掉了。但并非全部。这里就像是一场寻宝游戏，寻找它们，但它们确实在这里。
In the late 80s, the city's director of urban design at the time saw what was happening. This is a very subtle one. And put the word out to the rest of City Hall. If you're replacing your concrete furniture, he said, send it up to floor 19. We like it. Which is why today, whatever does remain,
在80年代末，时任该市城市设计总监的人看到了正在发生的事情。这是一个非常微妙的设计。并向市政厅的其他部门发出通知：如果你正在更换你的混凝土家具，他说，把它送到19楼。我们喜欢它。这就是为什么今天无论还剩下什么，
is still housed in the urban design offices, which are within the city planning department. There's a bit of it scattered elsewhere, too. The mayor still sits at a concrete desk. But mostly, floor 19 is the Florida of retired concrete furniture. You wouldn't notice the concrete unless you really squat down on the floor. The concrete legs are curved and smooth. The cabinetry is a little worse for wear. It's kind of furniture only an urban
仍然存放在城市设计办公室里，该办公室隶属于城市规划部门。其他地方也散落着一些。市长仍然坐在混凝土办公桌前。但大部分情况下，19楼就像是退休混凝土家具的佛罗里达州。除非你蹲到地板上，否则你不会注意到混凝土。混凝土桌腿弯曲而光滑。橱柜有点磨损。这是一种只有城市
designer could love. People like Robert Friedman who runs the urban planning office now. There are certain aspects of it that aren't that practical. It's really heavy. If you want to rearrange your office, you need to call a team of people in to help you do it. And I think most of the planners and urban designers written on 19th's, part of your training, right? You're exposed to the different eras of design. So I think there's an appreciation among our staff that may not exist among other divisions
设计者才会喜欢的家具。像现在负责城市规划办公室的罗伯特·弗里德曼这样的人。它有些方面确实不太实用。它真的很重。如果你想重新布置办公室，你需要叫一队人来帮你。我想规划师和城市设计人员在19楼写下的这些，是你训练的一部分，对吧？你会接触到不同时期的设计。所以我认为我们的员工有一种可能在其他部门不存在的欣赏水平
in the scene. Look at the spinch. Yeah. Though I have to say, the furniture really grew on me. Wow. That is actually very pretty. And I found myself sort of rooting for its survival, which is exactly what Masha Kalman's wants me to do. So the hope is that it's actual value as a rather important piece of, you know, uniquely
在场景中。看看这个靠垫。是的。不过我必须说，这些家具确实越来越讨人喜欢了。哇。这其实非常漂亮。我发现自己有点支持它能够存活下来，这正是玛莎·凯尔曼希望我做的事。所以希望它作为一件非常重要的、独特的
Canadian furniture design will be recognized and that it will receive the restoration and the protection that it deserves. Do you miss it? No. This episode of 99% Invisible was produced by Sean Cole and me Roman Mars with support from Lunar making a difference with creativity. I think life is much bigger than my old office desk. To be honest. It's a project of KALW, the American Institute of Architects San Francisco and the Center
加拿大家具设计的实际价值能够得到认可，并获得它应得的修复和保护。你会想念它吗？不会。《99%隐形》的这一期由肖恩·科尔和罗曼·马斯制作，并得到了用创意创造改变的Lunar的支持。老实说，我认为生活比我旧的办公桌要宏大得多。这是KALW、旧金山美国建筑师协会和中心联合制作的项目
for Architecture and Design. It's a nice desk though. I agree. To find out more, go to 99%invisible.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
为了解建筑和设计。不过这张桌子挺不错的。我同意。欲了解更多信息，请访问 99%invisible.org。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。